start meeting so the first thing is the
emergency evacuation evacuation
announcement I will read it the meeting
will be audio recorded should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the room by the door to
the fire escape staircase please hold
both handrails in case the stairs of wet
or slippery it has been raining tonight
as one if anyone is unable to use the
stairs but they please allow others to
exit the room before that I go to the
fire escape door where they can then be
given assistance our sampling point will
be in the public car park at the side of
the silk sweet do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings and
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by the
capstone thank you apologies for absence
once we've received in the office our
counselor meal counselor black and
counseling Toby mountain there will be
substituted by counselor mrs. Tuohy yes
are there any other apologies any not
members attending
council will ensure your something
alright minutes of the meeting held on
the twenty first of june two thousand
six stone do we agree great agreed item
for twisting declarations of interest
are there any item 5 is the external
audit form to those charged with
governance and to consider the report of
the section 151 off yourself on the
external auditors report on the results
of their audit and the council's
financial statement for 2 15 16 if you
can give that just in every one terabyte
introduced are queuing suitable from the
young children presenting this thank you
thank you so this report summarizes our
work on the orders of in 2015-16 and
what is your account i'm very pleased to
be able to say that by doing 10 to be
able to do an unqualified opinion your
accounts for the year however in the
respect of your values in many
arrangements I have afraid to report
that science let's give a qualified
opinion that your arrangements are in
place except for in regards to the
adequacy of the arrangements
vision of internal audits in respect to
the last year and only because the
resources were insufficient replace
fully internal its be able to give a
head of internal audit opinion and due
to the absence of some of the
arrangements in accordance with the
public sector internal audit standards
for example lack of achieve flawless
executive with special qualifications
and experience which in our judgments
are a significant deficiency in your
overall arrangements when we protected
our plan to this committee in March
which set out a number of risks that we
believed we would lead to focus our
working upon that time in respect to the
financial statements which is in section
3 of our reports page and five point 10
on multiple impacts we set out we'll be
looking at the risk of fraud in revenue
recognition to make sure the funds of
the council was spent and recorded
appropriately funded from the right
spots and particularly to make sure
that's capital expenditures by different
capital revenue from revenue sources in
particular very happy to report that we
found no is using this area and I can do
that we have assurance we're also
looking at the risk of management
overrides which is a common risk across
audits to make sure that the financial
statements were compared to a particular
a more out coming minds that did present
true and fair view by their outcomes of
the authority again very happy to be
able to convey to you that we didn't
find any evidence of that was the case
areas such as accounting estimates were
presented fairly we didn't find any
evidence actual bias and no significant
unusual
transactions we turn over the page
during our order to do come to our
attention however that's and there was
internal inconsistencies within this
painful predominately within notice 7
this is a particularly important note if
it takes out a number of accounting
items that should not be impacting upon
council tax so therefore we do the
closer to a page that is 5 11 5 11 make
it Roger never too far side some screens
are quite tragedy and then fold age I
bike 20 by the phone on the sunrise
begin so we pay particular attention to
this note to make sure the right areas
of it charged council tax and that items
that should be a spirit on council
tastes are therefore excluded we
identified some issues which management
have corrupted and therefore and
therefore those items now don't correct
me today to Aviva counseling and X item
them the important issue to raise on
that one is that a potentially issues
such as this should be either brought to
our attention a little bit earlier in
the audit or perhaps not not left and
for us to try and see see to resolve as
part of it and maybe an issue that
management might seem to be increasing
capacity or it or assistance earlier in
the accounting process moving on and
over to the page we highlight a number
of other issues that we identified two
observations or changes that they also
management to make in the statement of
accounts before you receive links listed
on on patient page five point 12 I'm not
going to go through all of those in
detail and I would be happy to take any
questions on those you may have darker
finish my presentation but the issue we
do have to bring to your attention is
that there isn't unadjusted and the
state unadjusted miss statements within
the accounts and which we set out in
Appendix A to our report this is a
disagreement between us over the
classification of the grant funding fee
amount teams just over 200,000 pounds
and we think briefly summarize this as
we think it goes in one place in the
statement of accounts in the income
statement of the lead to go to that
novel it won't make any difference to
your reserves it won't make any
difference to the outcome we are from uh
perspective happy to disagree it's not
going to make an impact upon my opinion
and I will still be able to give you an
unqualified opinion but we do need to
bring that to your attention because
above the level we said we will bring
any issues that management wouldn't
correct it and it's importantly you will
be able to take that into account in
your next item is seeking to a previous
statement of accounts for the year
turn into more detail for our value for
money inclusion earlier in the year in
March we identified that we had a risk
and regarding financial depression space
into Council and we set out the work
with undertaken on page 5 point 15
almonds in respect of the financial
pressures and we have a look at the
relation assassin creed busness of
assumptions using your annual budgeting
and medium term planning we have a look
at how you're prioritizing resources in
terms of your finances and your
performance try to match up the two to
make sure that the spending is
inappropriate areas and to meet the
corporate targets of the council and we
look at the progress and arrangements
looking forward to identify sufficient
savings to address the financial
pressures we aren't able to give you an
absolute assurance looking two or three
years ahead into the future everything's
going to be fine what we can do is take
a judgment on the arrangements that are
in place now and do we think you are on
the right track taking those issues into
account and in this respect I am happy
to be able to say yes we do believe
you're on the right track that's not to
underplay pressures the council is
facing but at the moment you do have
those arrangements in place to address
the challenges on page 51 point 17 we
then come to to the second item which
are already talked about which is and
the the lack of arrangement in our
judgment and to ensure that you have an
adequate internal audit coverage in
place for the financial year now we are
looking backwards into 2015-16 another
some members of this committee have
raised concerns previously in the
committee about the internal audit
coverage and my colleague Chris here was
that your last committee when the report
or the head an internal audit was
discussed in full the impact of other
oddities we do not believe therefore
that's not being able to draw an
internal audit opinion for the year and
lack of coverage in accordance with the
standards of the public sector old it
does it doesn't mean that this is it is
a lack of arrangements to ensure bounty
for money but we we do note that the
council is already moving to put rice on
those arrangements so you contacted or
invited essex county councillors
internal audit team to come in you have
a point in our chief or just executive i
understand how looking forward looking
to ensure that the arrangements are
adequate in 1617 we will of course have
a look at those next year just to make
sure those arrangements have been good
fully in place but in respective 2015-16
i will be getting a qualified conclusion
your value for money arrangements just a
couple of final tribal matters I do
reconfirm our independence from the
council it's important for the committee
to understand and then actually do
understand it to be aware that we are
independent and giving an independent
view not influenced in any way by any
and issues or I thought that objectivity
and and lastly just do outline that we
do is do we do expect to be discussing a
reasonable increase in the fee with a
section 151 officer at the end of our
audits this is a multi issues we set out
in appendix e which is on page five
point 24 particularly with regard to
lead to the issues around those seven
and any adjustments in errors that we
identified and the the work around the
significant risk in relation to the
value for money
delusion I'd be happy to take any
further questions about committing here
thank you there wasn't quite a lot in
that to take in and I think for the
kamati to taking and let any thank you
Kevin Oh 8511 you talk about web 7 and
you're saying this it should not have
been born to you have actually been
asking is this should have actually
possessed by the internal organ is this
something going forward that you expect
and with the appointment of the new
called it director that that would not
be placed in future or is it some to be
addressed on processes into I I think
it's probably not willing to remake
something new internal its director I
think is more about the the finance
department the processes from in the
finance department if man it may be
covered by the internal auditor thing is
more likely to be our responsibility
rather than those in the in terms of
those technical accounting issues so
going forward to prevent this kind of
thing happening again are you seeing
like things in place to make sure that
does actually correct yourself I always
the work needing to be young we've only
just identified the arrow result is I
think it's a little bit early for me to
give a comment on that we've made our
recommendation we would be we would need
to follow that one up in our next
assorted it might be more appropriate
needs to deceive your section 151 offers
a might be related to introspect I mean
I'll just very briefly explain how this
came about to be fair it's if you read
this all that this all issue would have
been actually come up because we were
seamen in balancing the budget
unfortunately added
it's exactly equal and opposite error we
have 400,000 11 our 400,000 the other so
they actually balanced out so for our
point of view everything looked ok we
followed Anibal checkers we would have
done normally there's only once the so
Kevin and team actually started to dig
into it did actually find one of the
entries was wrong and one to unravel II
did you see there was two actual parts
that were wrong to it and following the
discussion we kept them we then went
back to I am obviously partner work that
we get from myself as long pipeline from
Essex we've got one of the specialist
accountants informatics to come in from
morning so what's worked for the issue
and then you know it was sorted within a
couple of hours so to be fair if would
it happen again it could quite possibly
i mean if you have the sort of the
chance of actually being an eagle and
offset and fairly slim but i don't
finish xmas bed again but we do have
obviously the resources part of the
moran of understanding there sitting
under my role that we have got very very
specialist technical accountants that we
can call me if needs be so you know i'm
confident something like this wouldn't
happen again by i'm not going to say it
can't because i'd like to say all our
account always perfect though they never
will yeah so effectively you say this is
just a one-off rare fine fine from my
sloppy you let me get within the system
yeah no absolutely not not any other
questions there's anything else you'd
like to say of the in response to the
external auditors i mean i think the
only obviously thing obviously we're
disappointed that the the value for
money conclusion has come out as you
know we do recognize the worst it my
area i will promote from a from an
officer point of view we do recognize
there is a there was a short coming in
the internal audit function you know
that's been put in place with with greg
and team and actually going forward we
think that's been you know the also
significantly and study from the word
from the peer review we don't bury his
conversations with herbs than young with
kevin and chris about you know whether
they could do any more testing on their
into actual each one time valid
the actual the value for money Pete's
themselves rather than just relying on
their head of internal audits opinion
and that was the one question we can
never still get to an answer to where
you know why would they have to rely
jaffe early on the head of internal
audit opinion when actually would there
not be any more testing that Ernst &
Young could do on that but then equally
I recognized the staging that says
actually the internal audit function
wasn't present in it and it wasn't
reasonable that the right size it should
be so whether that would actually be
enough to swing in either way I think
this is something that has certainly
been talked about in audit committee for
for some time which is why the peer
review came into place and there were
things put into place down to rectify it
so as external auditors are you happy
the things that have been put into place
to rectify to the best of my knowledge
of the present time yes we haven't done
a lot of work in detail we are assured
you are taking steps and we will now say
we will come back and revisit that next
year but I wouldn't expect that the the
council has done sufficient this would
not be repeated yeah you probably aren't
going to like this question but it's
because i am not totally i'll say with
whose responsibility for which different
wrong so am i apologize but you know the
comment about we couldn't rely on
internal audit because they didn't have
the staffing and you know the resources
to do not either external auditors would
it not be your responsibility to then
check that just to see that you that
that was okay or not is enough that
respect isn't what we paid for it's the
responsibility of the section 151
officer to make sure that
acknowledgments are in place and
obviously with the support of his
colleagues and effectively we have
now reported on this anthology of those
arrangements were to place as far as we
were aware through the year and there is
that we were directly relying on
internally in the financial systems that
work was being done but as it came
towards the end of the year it was clear
that with the inability to be able and
results the peer review to make that
conclusion that the wider arrangement of
the council in our judgment has
deficiency so even though it was
mentioned at previous audit meetings
that we that we were concerned that this
wasn't in place at which you would have
been at those meetings you didn't pick
up on that we picked up on it we didn't
believe at that present at that time it
was so significant that it was but it
was absolutely thank you up if I could
just a lot honey what you and sound as
well i'm not sure if it would be the
responsibility of the external something
is said the responsible at section 151
office around where we had some issues
over section 151 officers during the
year on current models in the first one
for instance it's so that that might be
an issue but i'm really concerned that
we as a committee i was on the committee
last year by using the collective
highlighted the issue last year and that
wasn't picked up by our officers or we
didn't convey the seriousness or the
officer didn't understand the
seriousness of it is a concern to me
because this was something that was
picked up by the religious i think there
i think it was really tough in as much
as that's part we got the one the peer
review is never really found out that so
and I appreciate that how so justice so
sorry I just feel that if it was picked
up then just so coming back again it was
very slowly picked up he said a very
slow and painful process but from what I
understand the time would have been
December assemble this was raised the
peer review happened in january-february
and greg was in place in april so i
couldn't we couldn't have done this much
quicker to be fair but it was recognized
there wasn't efficiency and the level of
effort was
in pretty quick to get things resolved
but clearly what we needed was say
appear in you to be able to wear exactly
what it had been easy to assign there is
the deficiency in order and left it
there we sort of knew coming in cold I
knew that we had one and a half to two
staff there we should have three four
five it depends but what needed to be
done with an external view of that to
say exactly what happened hence the peer
review at the time you know then the
results of the peer review were digested
we had to know maybe a week or two weeks
of management decision and then we
engage dcct to get Greg into place oh
sorry a head of internal audience apply
so to be fair I don't think there was a
massively time it wasn't certainly
wasn't the full year I can't guarantee
that so there wasn't a lot we rushed
Greg in as quickly as we could to be
fair so but I take your point top tech
downlods understood those issues from so
did former SEC 10 problems but she
that's not the case that's not the case
any further questions
so the no further questions the
recommendation is these would propose
that the committee resolves that the
report we noted and the implementation
of any action plans be reported through
the audit process and that the chairman
of the audit committee you can sign a
statement as outlined in its report just
one final comment I would still like to
place my thanks on the finance team for
all their cooperation held during the
audience and we have raised a number of
issues here they have been extremely
helpful open and their cooperation has
been a very much appreciated the condo
place scrutinize pain and in the
contactor audit I just would like place
out record thank you very much and I'm
sure they appreciate that thank you so
the next item in item 6 which is the
financial statements
is that yep Thank You chair so it's a
weighty time to say and I really does
propose to go for replicating every
number snow I will give you a very quick
highlight what's in there and some of
the key pages and then I won't open up
to questions and then talk about 10 to
what the changes are next year as well
because you need to be aware of those so
so local government finance at the
moment is on a bit of a journey so
believe it or not these are supposed to
be the most readable account so far that
you've ever had but I believe that I
certainly done and I big changes coming
in next year to make them even more
readable and supposedly concise is that
true and that going to be more relatable
be there will be two or three schedules
in there will be easier for us to
reconcile between certain things yes but
they're still going to be a wait it's
still going to be very detailed and
actually you know this there's a section
of the back now you'll know which is
Brandon which is called the narrative
statement and the idea behind this was
it's supposed to be a bit of an outer
report it's a bit of a report that says
this is what's happened in the council
this is the financial overview and this
sort of gives a bit of an explanation of
how the performance dates have links to
some of the risks to some of the
financial statements is supposed to give
us a bit more of a verbal update as such
on what's going on this is the first
year we've ever done it its first to
anyone's ever done it and to be honest
the results are some areas have done two
pages we're up to about 35 i think so it
all it all depends you know we're going
to settle this down so yeah this
appendix 1 in the in the report and I
want bringing it up while it white key
is obviously even there is is a these
lots of different things together I
first give a much more own have a bit
more of a flavor of what actually goes
on so just you're aware of that but any
questions on that i'll give those in
there in a second so but if we come back
to the actual to the front page of the
report
the financial statement and what we're
actually presenting to you ease is a
couple of key areas so this is the what
we call the incoming expenditure
statement the CI es it's the balance
sheet it's the cash flow statement and
it's something called the MERS the
movement in reserves and the reserves is
quite fundamental to local government
and most of what this done if this is
this is our account for the year and
what it does it tries to link up all of
the expenditure the income our council
tax business rates things like that with
also things on our balance sheet
appreciation capital expenditures
various things so and what i can tell
you i'm very pleased to tell you is we
had originally planned to to have a
general fund balance which is basically
the amount of money we have left which
is not ring fence which we have left
after council tax and it's basically our
savings pop that we've built up so it is
a reserve but it's not reserved we had
for anything else we had plans to have
1.2 million in there at the end of this
year and we ended up with a year with
1.1 75 at a shortfall of around 35,000
so I'm reasonably comfortable with that
to be honest on that's what a number so
we've you know this year but what we
actually did we'd under spent on our
budgeting figures by about 1.1 million
so what we've been able to do is
actually move that 1.1 million over to
the reserves to our to fund our
transformation programmes and things
like that so that's more than a mule
here so we also like say we managed to
hit our general balance which is like
saying that the savings the reserves
that we don't what we can spend on
whatever we like a rainy day money in
effect and I was also still putting lots
of money into reserves to help us with
our transformation programmes and sub
such
and what it's also important here is the
where are we also had the capital
program this year so capital pub so in
1516 the capture program and plan to
spend 4 million a big chunk of that was
going to be on the waist vehicles which
was which was all spent back in the
summer and that's double in and running
and saved us an amount of money on our
revenue budget which is good and then we
have a bit of an understand so we
actually spent 3.1 million in total and
with what that is is split between areas
that just we just didn't spend on the
capital program and other areas that
didn't get spent in 1516 that will be
carried forward so the biggest bulk of
that is about 400,000 on the depo you
should be aware of them there's about
30,000 on the pavilion and in bits and
pieces on some of the car parks around
there around the district as you've seen
in 1617 our capital programs shrunk
considerably from these figures we've
reduced it down to more like a three
hundred thousand pound capture program
so this was the last year of us really
going out with a big bang to spend our
money 1617 is obviously a much more
frugal prudent year we were looking at
capital maintenance versus building new
things just so when you start to see
that contrast okay so I set out out
reserves are still looking fairly
healthy so we've moved from a position
of 1.8 million as we started the year in
1516 he ended the year at nearly 2.9
million and these are things we call the
ear marked reserved so these are
reserves that have a specific purpose
the breakdown you see on on page six
point four was the breakdown as was in
1516 for 1617 we've reordered days and
changed the names of that you've a
little bit more flavor of what they do
because these are quite generic title so
when you look at the 1617 breakdown
you'll achieve and make a lot more sense
for things up transformation we've got
things like legal in their housing stuff
like that so if you just have a look
it's not we're not trying to hide things
from you is just we have that's how we
opened the years and that's how we have
to finish
and then like I say so obviously
reporting back on honor killings
position so we had made it a number of
so we've got we produced the draft
reports at the end of June they have to
be put on our website as our draft
accounts and then there opens for anyone
to question and interpret I don't think
we had any moves at the public our sins
any question of sweetener obviously then
Kevin and team coming to to audit us
since then we've made a couple of
changes as kevin has reported based on
the work that we've done and that meant
that the figures are the reserves are as
I've just explained that we hit 1.1
million in our general fund our original
estimate was original plan was 1.5
million but we had incorrectly accounted
for that 400,000 as we said so it didn't
fundamentally change what we had spent
it was just how it was accounted for in
the reserves now I'll pause there at
that point because the them that we get
right into the actual figures in the day
too and I'll be honest I'm not proposing
to go through them unless anyone's got
any particular questions it can be quite
a party we've got any questions it's not
unreasonable is just really
clarification around and rotation on the
f-86 436
what signals weak 6437 okay with it
rises only up running through early i'm
not regularly from ruined okay we have
them in five six point three seven
towards the top we've got the details of
the will exit packages that they sort of
redundancy in the old vocabulary we've
got 150 thousand and one thousand seven
thousand pounds to people yeah obviously
it was 298 there thousand five hundred
fifty seven pounds which comes out one
person must be next 150 I understand
that there was thirteen 269 added on to
it yeah however you look at the one
below he was added on to the head of
leading estates & M services which meant
head of Environmental Services which
must be the only other person who could
be in there for Jimmy's 114,000 that
very quickly on okay night so I saw
hundreds of time while is time 31 still
give can stay there and 143 96 set up to
311 2827 which is the same as the 298
557 in the table above and the 13 to
file one pair which are so I believe
that we should open only one redundancy
under the hundred fifty thousand and one
pound to two hundred thousand pound and
there should be another bandage is
missing there which is 120 thousand one
pound to 150,000 pounds of another one
individual person because one of them is
not he's under 150 thousand two hundred
forty and rook 396 yeah I'm seeing where
you only long maybe just look at that
sorry excuse me just so I all the bright
sunny perfect nor any just think once we
haven't and the reason for that well
actually we did highlight into the eyes
where it is but because we reported that
being a previously in currently we have
to continue that is here that first you
want to change your important faster
incorrect anything it's reported to
shivering correction yes Shalini
perpetuity we reported we don't leave
don't leave the last year being a dog so
I don't know that's fourteen fifteen
isn't it yeah in 15 years service we
would have to show as a restatement in
that table yes in which objective
restate to do anyway it's not been go
ahead and pick restage getting laid help
you if you're exactly properly you
shouldn't be corrected properly sure I
think that's a fair one little but
that's the only got everybody costs
every single page and that was the only
real plan we reach the benefit of having
an accountant on me or do I have fun I
do that I'll slightly very quick I'm
sorry we can bow ties up to the final
version bills thank you iska thank you
just one generald query as I'm reading
through by noticed there are a few
things that jumped out at me in
particular page 672 talking about the
next on the pension liability this is
next actuarial valuation the LV on the
thirty-first a large 16 yes that will
kind of make me think walking on minute
is this an old report has this not been
revisited again 691 lat code will be
considered by for council and 2016
this is because it was based on the 15
16 figures so we if we were to put
anything new in there it would impact
after the end of the date of these
accounts right so this we raising hands
were prepared so if you wanna clear so
this statement is up to march 2016 right
31st Amar's 2016 and this would be as of
the first so that impact evaluation with
impact as of the first of april twenty
six then onwards which is after the
dates of these accounts so i read it and
i do agree but we can't change our
thoughts because if we put in the new
valuation it wouldn't be correct because
it's last year's figures that's what
it's based on thank you okay any other
questions hi friends at the point on the
narrative run of course the game is not
I haven't run it be picky sometimes
they're just funny how to get nothing oh
it's just really have some of these
things just beginning these percentages
again which we pay for happened before
open page 6.62 yeah not really English
it doesn't really make any sense
eighty-six percent of residents and fall
of their independence is increased so
should it be recited six percent of
residents who had housing adaption that
debt receipts yet being sort this is
yeah as a matter of English ivy
ninety-five percent of residents right
rocks receptions pic with attendees okay
and we caught that before where the
number have responded through as well
the hunters or something and it's been
said it makes us a good yeah now about
particularly pick up the load sweetness
which in turn the word in that's good
thank you
so are we happy for mr. filin straight
into the recommendation based on the
adjustment for ya of course get with my
mercenary adjustments yet so the
recommendation is proposal to make
yourselves but the financial statements
be approved and signed by the chairman
and that the movement is earmarked
reserves in that movement in earmark
preserves be latitude my artist had one
more point to gene obviously which was
the statement that kept in mind if you
don't mind rip which is the difference
of opinion between ourselves ah 222,000
like i said we have got in one part of
the income statement and evil and ernst
& young bulimia should be somewhere else
the bottom line it doesn't change it
doesn't change any of the meaning of the
accounts is purely a classification
between one line and another but it did
say that it doesn't matter in you i want
to point affect our opinion so i'm going
to fit the opinion i just wanna make
that clear we know that part of the
decision as well sounds happy that it's
not affecting opinions can you just
explain then to us why it is the you go
through okay right of course so there is
something called the circle which is
basically the reporting guidelines that
say this is how you should report
various things and that's what i've been
an abuse it says in quite clearly
intercom you should do this yeah we use
the social sip fairies are counting body
accounted the accounting body of given
guidelines as well to say this is how
you should account the things 99.9 under
scent of them are exactly the same but
on this particular item they are
different so we are using our accounting
guidelines that says this is this and
answer young you're using what's called
a circle and it's basically a very gray
area and we both think we're right I'm I
precedent on it is the fact that circle
is disappearing next year so I'm going
to take a look
slight advantage of that and Sam well
actually if we did this we'd have to
change it back next year so can I where
can we use sort of surmise from that
then the next year will be deferring to
your allocation yes y'know convincingly
different committees were here I bet
that's fair accumulation reweaving one
document property of the other we're
happy it is great at anything instead an
issue the committee should i think it is
an issue that should prevent your proven
financial statements in front of you
because we're still going to give it a
solid understanding that's yeah that is
is the important to get under the fire
so so are we happy without them Griffin
a great expert ok thank you are 27 new
arrangements to appoint external
auditors so that is to consider the
joint report from a section 151 officer
and assistant director democratic
services are new arrangements for
pointing the council's external auditors
oh yeah you're going to Thank You chair
yep a lot maintenance or even so I
basically
the think about it yeah so we have to
basically up when you auditors quite
December 17 and deal with Ernst & Young
would only take us up to the end of next
year takes up to yeah 17 18 year and so
we need to consider actually doing that
as a procurement so summarizing we've
basically got three options we can
create our Nordic panel and go an
appoint her own external auditors for a
procurement exercise we can work with a
few other councils and create a joint
already panel and do the same thing or
there is a the public sector audit
appointments limited has come together
which basically a national surveys that
said they will procure one out the
powerful and so fundamentally for us
from a office of one of you we recommend
that the final point that says we join
the national system because one it
should be cheaper and two it's actually
going to guarantee which we should be
able to get a good service but clearly
it's it's a member decision whether you
feel you won't have a much more of an
input into our external auditors are
versus just giving some guidance to a
another body to do it on our behalf so
that's fundamental the report an issue
we have so that would require having a
panel window yes yeah i'll be honest
again from my point of view it's
obviously far better for us as we
obviously parked something bigger when
we guarantee more value for money yes
absolutely but you from that you will
see the other side because you will give
up slight control but the other side of
it is you know how much control do you
have over X done order anyway they are
very prescriptive and what they do sorry
is it easy that's the decision is you
guys need to make something
thank you do things number one in the
report it does actually make it clear
that the success of this is down to the
amount of councils that take out the
option yep on this how can we be sure
that this is going to be a success that
phantoms are going to take this up and
so I've had a discussion of what's
called the FIS ex-fiancé officers
association on pretty seven hundred
percent of those guys order to go for it
as well so that's 15 local authorities
all within Essex that's certainly going
to be interested in this so I'll be
honest if you know if we consider this
and it doesn't go ahead it doesn't look
like it's working we need to see what
the timing could be whether we could
just join an Essex group ourselves which
is almost option B and see what time
we've got as well so it's through an
obviously one option on the table okay
second question no cost things seem to
be anywhere in this at all we've got no
idea of figures we now can we base a
decision or recommendation or with no
figures but we can't we don't know until
we go to procurement unfortunately
because we have no idea what the
procurement costs are you doing rusty
and so if I go back to the whole like
inquiries the Ernst & Young costs for
this year which was 47,000 pounds so so
clearly we'd be looking to get a deal
close to forty seven thousand pound but
we we have an idea and if most of the
Essex authorities are van with the LGA
then if we wanted to join in with a
panel locally there would be no Essex
authorities left to join him within your
aunt alone they do that fact that make
sense it doesn't have it helps from the
clients I involved with in Suffolk and
Norfolk all of those are opting in to
the National arrangements one at least
the ones i learned directive on
this is the common decision thank you
for that because I'm sort of think after
joining us outside thank you and I was
also concerned about the cost is there
was no costumes mentioned me but by what
time when's a deadline we've got to make
a decision so if you're talking about
for some time yes we need to decide
whether we're going to be in the central
port by December 16 so no matter the
questions so I thought if the last
meeting we do discuss this and also put
them on another Authority I know we all
remember if excessive costs on that
authorities about today I know we
discuss this last time is over complete
mapping in the training actually for you
can obtain the brass and although we do
talk that I'm sure with your breakfasts
then that may not be afforded a minor
saying is the costs aren't expected to
be any more but the central for needs
expected to be the cheapest method
regard to what costs oh and I think you
know I think it's at the training your
training at univ just sorry counselor
slaton what is the question again do i
hear you right when you first started
talking tonight that we are even we have
actually now appointed an audit director
so we've appointed until year-end Essex
County Council which is represented by
Greg and I believe John Bostock will be
presenting to you reasonably certain on
the next door to community to plans for
the future years from my point of view I
can tell you that we put in budget aside
for full-time rollers engine turn or it
currently great as soon as he's being
paid for from the audit reserve we set
up so that will run out at the end of
first of April so we need to have a
budget in place that's all i can to
refurbish the short-term contract
Soviet view we have a Memorandum of
Understanding between the two councils
have you a lot yes any further questions
until seven the recommendation is it's
proposing the Committee recommends to
council that the council ops into a
proposed central arrangements for
appointing external auditors we agreed
that all right item a play another one
from this bench planning but review of
the council's corporate risk management
and registers yeah okay so so what I do
is the corporate risk management process
and the register for 1617 I'll draw your
attention to the fact that this hasn't
changed hardly talked since the the
process for 15 16 and then update the
specific changes on the actual register
so the process the framework was put in
place last year from my my predecessor
Bernie's Mary's that will let this
through currently we're working towards
these we have regular reporting of risks
and performance at the leadership
support team at the loose your team
members each get over a performance pack
give you some of the key indicators and
key risk what's going on we are so the
risk area I look after particularly this
year now it's not necessarily in the
report is I want to get them much more
proactive about what they're doing to it
it's good that we report risks and we
talk about them but I very much want to
see whether the so wats or what's
happening next what we doing about is
proactively managing these risks out of
the organization and that's something
we've not done particularly well in the
past and we [ __ ]
very good standing back and reporting
what has happened but that's about
what's actually coming up and how do we
deal with them what are we doing to
mitigate and so that's very much stuff
that the guys in my team are working
towards now with some updated reporting
we're doing and then much more like a
business partnering type reionization
with yourselves so the actual framework
has such hasn't particularly Chinese
websites around them if you know wording
changes things like you know removing a
Mars roll and putting Shawn and Nick
into place in terms of the wording but
otherwise it's fairly standard if we
move to our page if we come to page
eight point one nine which is the actual
corporate risk register for 1617 so this
is fundamentally as a summarized version
of individual risk registers that each
director at hult and as you can see it's
done on a on a likelihood an impact
rating to give a bit of a risk now the
ones i obviously draw your attention to
are the three hires the first one being
there is a serious food or health or
safety environmental incident which the
council is culpable now I believe that
it raised as an issue before and hence
we've kept it as high because it is
something that is very you know taken
very seriously by by officers and
members alike and that work continues on
that for a number of food interventions
food inspections and things like that to
make sure that we you know we don't fall
foul with this the second one being the
one that I've actually changed this year
and that's the risk to actually
producing a balanced budget and they an
NTFS or our future financial data geez
actually we can fund ourselves it's
become apparent that we still have a gap
in future years and that you know there
is a risk there that we're not going to
achieve that so therefore we need to
break it as high as it is quite likely
we're quite a lot of god the right
processes in place but if we get any
more sort of financial shocks that the
council is gonna have to do something
fairly drastic to try and meet
those challenges so it needs to be hive
has a high risk and it'd be a big impact
if we can't so and then final one which
has been around already which is the
inability to recruit and retain staff
Attica and to keep them so as you know
we are you know we are lean moment our
staffing that was a very lame as you
know where you know we are working very
well under the pressure obviously
there's pressure he's there for staff so
what sean has put in place at the moment
he's doing a bit of a stress review of
each of the directorate's and asked us
to come up with their where our staff
particularly overstretched where is
there any motivational issues where we
got any D motivating factors things like
that so we can actually start to see as
a leadership team where we've got
potential issues with staffing and we're
also going to start implementing much
more of the any exit interviews of stuff
that do leave obviously we do review our
long-term sickness quite closely as well
so all these things are in place to try
and mitigate that risk obviously it's
things like that that has to be
considered that you learned about the
pause at that point any questions on
that sorry I'm I'm never very fatiguing
risk registers clinical agree the risk
well about to exercise no no I think
it's very wide-ranging I think sometimes
you need to build it and I do have a
clearly on model on page a clue 19 in
respect to their aldi report and item 12
base your money we've got like a bit of
two but then they verified will be gone
yeah the base of it I'm kind of justify
to or should it be through he still
comes out as medium to yeah so but i
think that
you should be more yeah I mean have a
full report listing actually be
recognizing the risk register I think my
interpretation of this from our
perspective we difference in three hours
corporal Rangers items i was talking
specifically about the human right thing
we didn't identify any concerns around
per kid song ends interpreter so that's
all right from our heads indoors as i
think is to insist thank you thank you
thank you both thank you can page 8.21
boarding got very good expect emotional
issues that we've got overly themselves
the safety one of the concerns berries
under your listing near the quality of
controls is poor yeah it's being done by
there I mean surely I mean risk is high
yeah ensuring their the action should be
responsive to their it doesn't sort of
thing to equation we recognized it as
being I yep what could seek the quality
of the controller support will get which
is something to be celebrated with their
theories that my heart I'll be honest I
can't answer specifically because it
it's not an area on as close to as I
should be but and it's a recognition
that there are levels there poor levels
of control and therefore that something
we need to address but that's what that
age being a trip absolutely yes
certainly but why can't do is give you
specific examples at mother [ __ ] like
but when I can bring that back i think
my understanding of that was was the and
again registering to to do the
inspections that was mentioned before
we're back to problem we've raised with
better staff and with audit before so
would like to have it from my point of
view have it noted that we would like to
see that address for next the next time
is anybody do you agree with of that you
don't know i can ask the waiter to
prepare a paper on a desert play around
or before the next committee review
behind it because because it's a my
understanding was it was it was letter
staffing but that was previously and if
we still got Mecca staffing or not
enough to do the inspection because that
is a very serious reputational risk to
his reputation risk to our council but
it's also a limiter is risk to our
residents and I think it should be
addressed imperfectly for my journal on
where at the moment that Louisa is
leading on an internal restructure
within her team so I think as part of
that restructure that is being addressed
starting numbers and relevant officers
in relevant roles well perhaps it just
could be noted from the audience we've
noted that and you would like something
from don't just work it is possible to
do that in so again the this is a new
audit plan internally plan does include
an order of of this area linking example
the coverages directed towards the risky
areas so in court for you will receive a
return internal audit report which will
provide an independent opinion upon the
progress being made and the strength of
controls in place so that would be a in
addition to the assistant directors
report that you've requested another
layer of assurance which you can take
into consideration
I'll so just a quick follow-up question
you actually know what but Sean's doing
a good staff morale yeah I just
wondering is that an issue moving the
local authorities then where is it just
doing just in case it's probably too
i'll be honest these two sites now you
know rochford district council has gone
through significant change over the last
few years so I think it'd be nice for me
to say everything is fantastic and
morale was amazing but yeah the change
have happen and I've settled now to be
fair hasn't been you know much or
changing the number so I think you know
what to finding their new way of working
different and I think most people are
are fairly receptive to that lacks a
sean is leading this piece on it on the
stress specifically the leaner is also
another work stream as part of what
Nikki's doing about the business plan
which is around people and culture
change so it's about how do we also
change as an organization to be much
more flexible get people out of their
silos of this is my job and that's the
only job I do where is actually we are
150 staff we are so few we have to be
able to flexible across and I think some
of that some stuff could be fairer well
communities and welcome am i doing in
finance oh really welcome in that taking
people out the silos and moving them
around so I'd like to certainly say from
my of my world I think it's fairly good
whether that's reflective across the
whole counter I think you're being
presumptuous of me to say yes and we
call it go sighs of that report when
it's done and I've talking Sean the
finite where where he's intending to put
it yet again anything else
so it is proposed the committee resolves
that the updated corporate risk
management policy and frame will be
approved and at the content of the
corporate risk register 2016-17 be noted
railing and I was there no doubt that
the yeah collecting bottles of Genovia I
29 exclusions pressing public and then
as for public here so we take that as
read item 10 audit report for return